cela va faire trois ans que notre chaîne
a vu le jour il en réalité arte france
fait partie d'une aventure bien plus
vaste entamé il ya maintenant 15 ans en
effet le 10 décembre 2005 une chaîne
alors nommé russia today y était lancée
proposant des journaux télévisés et
autres programmes sur la russie en
langue anglaise
l'objectif à l'époque améliorer l'image
du pays à l'étranger pour sortir du
cliché froid vodka balalaïka à l'époque
il était difficile d'imaginer dans
quelle mesure ce projet allait
bouleverser enrichir diversifié l'agenda
mondial d actualité toujours des
dizaines de millions de personnes dans
de nombreux pays regard des libertés
c'est une voie à laquelle on fait
confiance et qui est respecté et disons
le franchement c'est aussi la voie de la
vérité que certains craignent et qu'il
préférerait faire taire en quinze années
le réseau télévisé rt s'est hissé à la
hauteur des grandes chaînes
internationales occidentale tout en
gardant sa singularité
[Musique]
rt n'hésite pas à poser les questions
les plus gênantes ce n'est pas du tout
une chaîne conciliante
contrairement à l'image que certains
cherchent à en donner ce n'est pas du
tout le cas et le niveau des
journalistes qui travaillent pour rt
suscite un profond respect une des
recettes du succès de rt sa forte
présence sur internet et les réseaux
sociaux et au moment des remerciements
celles et ceux qui nous suivent de près
ou de loin ne sont pas oubliés un grand
espace historique
merci infiniment d'avoir créé cette
chaîne ça fait déjà 15 ans que cette
chaîne est aux côtés de ses
téléspectateurs et je tiens à remercier
en particulier notre public
chaque téléspectateur chaque spectateur
sur youtube chaque abonné tous ceux qui
lisent nos réseaux sociaux et n'incite
chacun d'eux ce qu'ils nous croient
qu'ils nous regardent qui discutent avec
nous ou tout simplement qui prennent
plaisir parce qu'il ya une voix
divergentes dans
une voix qui diffère du taurine anime
des voix identiques qui était toujours
le même avant notre naissance ce qui est
précieux sécurité travail brillamment
mieux que les autres sous la forme du
multimédia parce qu'aujourd'hui une
chaîne isolé ne peut pas exister c'est
impossible
seule une structure multimédia des
chances de survivre et de remporter la
compétition
ce que vous faites avec succès alors
bien sûr il y aura toujours des voix qui
s'élèveront pour nous décrédibiliser
mais cela fait partie du jeu quand on
exerce un métier public
quoi qu'il en soit le chemin parcouru
ces quinze dernières années prouve
assurément que rtc fait une place au
coeur du paysage médiatique mondiale